Do you want to do the intro for me? It's what's popping.
Well.
Hey guys. So this interview is split into three parts.
If you're new to this channel, you probably came here for part one.
Now for part two and three,
this is for my subscribers for people who care about sun. Me,
not a lot of people do,
but for some of you here is the chance to get to know her. And yeah,
it's pretty fun. And uh,
I hope you guys learned something and I hope you guys have fun watching this
video. What's popping guys.
Welcome to another tech show where we give tips and tricks on how to land a
successful career in tech. You're just moving your eyebrows.
[Inaudible].
Cool. So today, as you can see, we have a special guest [inaudible].
Hi everyone. And send me.
Not the K-pop star. Unfortunately, just a, just a software engineer.
But you know, it's,
it's better than nothing that today what we're going to talk about,
we're just going to talk about some me's journey on how she got into software
engineering and it was highly requested. So, you know,
and she would also request it to be on my videos.
That's why I asked her here because she backed me. So, all right, carry on.
Let's see why. So, so,
so before we begin, short bullet questions,
Mac or PC Mac, nice iPhone or Android,
easy choice. Favorite language, Korean,
favorite programming language. Favorite programming, language.
Python. Nice.
Nice. I like Python two, a favorite editor.
Oh, Ooh, no.
No. What's wrong with them.
I used to use them a lot, but now I think he makes us better.
Really? All right. Coffee or tea? Coffee.
Nice hint. Or like Croix. What? Wait, wait,
why do you work with [inaudible].
Like the sparkling water.
Dude. Hint has sparkling water by the way. No, no, no. Yeah.
Marketing, take it out.
Okay. [inaudible].
Okay. Cool. All right. So let's talk about your journey to software engineering.
Where'd you go to high school in?
Um, I went to high school in China, actually.
Wait, shoot, Korean.
I'm Korean.
So I was born in Korea and I lived there until another elementary
school. And then I went to Beijing for my multiple high school.
Oh, fascinating. Fascinating. So wait,
so why did you go to China?
I think it was a combination of my dad's work as well as my mom wanted to give
me a better education by sending me to an international school.
Nice. So did you do any CS classes when you were there? No. No. So wait,
when was it.
Also didn't have any CS? Yeah.
And either so, but like most, apparently most American schools,
they have CS in high school.
Yeah. That was not a thing here. And then what'd you do after,
after high school? I came to the U S for college or was it a Stanford?
Sanford? I've never heard of it. What is it?
Yeah, it was just like school and California or I suppose it's in Paul.
So if I ever heard of it, it's not bad. It's like decent.
Okay. Is it? I heard it was okay for, I heard it's kind of like,
it's like Waterloo, but United States. Right.
Did you have a Waterloo?
Okay. Now I know what it is. Cool. Cool. Yeah. So how did you get in Sam?
I mean, I mostly applied to you at schools, so same exact process,
online applications.
[inaudible] in China.
Okay. What was your sat score?
Okay. It's 2380.
It doesn't mean much to me.
That's pretty impressive.
All right. Yeah. So, so at Stanford, uh what'd you study computer science. Okay.
And then,
but Stanford was like the only time that you first learned how to code, right?
Yup. I actually did not know how to code at all before coming to Stanford.
So yeah,
my first CS class was a Java class.
Actually.
It wasn't a teleclass it was programming fundamentals that was caught in some
form of Java. That was your first course.
That was my very first exposure to the programming.
And then I guess you fell in love with it.
Yeah. Um, I really liked the professor who taught,
uh, classes because Stanford places,
all of their celebrity professors into their, uh,
beginner classes so that everyone will get on it and then they'll get hooked on.
So they will take yes, more CS classes.
So then I'm guessing just two more CS classes and then more and more.
And did you do any internships? Yeah.
I did too. And the two internships,
one at ABT and I didn't want to like
advocate software engineer and LinkedIn. I was an apartment.
Oh, so you did both like, what'd you like more than.
It's really different. I mean, I'm an engineer right now,
so I ultimately chose engineering, but, um,
they're really different. PM is much less technical.
At least the role I had was pretty on I'm very technical and engineering.
It's like all coding. So different looks.
Now you're an engineer. And then what kind of engineer are you?
I'm? Uh, I'm Mo I work mostly on backend. Do you ever think about.
Trying like iOS or Android or do you like backend? You want to say?
I think I want to be really solid in the backend before I expand,
but I'm definitely interested in older device.
Got it, got it. Okay. Did you get a lot of good grades in school?
Nice, nice high school. College. I would say college. Like,
did you get like a grazing? Do you think that matters for, um,
for getting hired for internships.
In college? I would say I did get good grades.
Um, but it does not really matter.
Hmm. Okay. So not that much. So, so what matters more is like.
Your experience? Um.
So what about like your first internship?
Because I'm guessing you didn't have any experience.
Okay. I guess if you're a freshman and looking for a very first internship,
you need to show everything you can in order to prove yourself.
So GPA would help, but then again, it's only a freshman GPA,
so it doesn't mean that much, but it's better than a really low GPA.
So did you study a lot for, for the grade to God? Like, like,
were you just studying all day,
like at school or did you do a lot of extracurriculars?
I was involved in a lot of different student groups. Um,
so I think it was a healthy balance of studying and also meeting new people,
especially when you are, you have to meet new people. That's like, well,
freshman year is four. So I don't know if you did that. I don't know.
Ah, yeah. Okay. Funny story.
So I lived in a dorm and our dorm was next to a club, like,
like a pretty ratchet club. Yeah. It was, it was called fills or something.
Cause I lived at Laurier people from Waterloo, you would understand, but yeah.
And every,
every Wednesday night I would hear like stuff and I would be just
like a little theater either studying or like, you know?
Yeah. I mean, I wasn't a loner, like I have friends, but it's just,
I didn't like to go out. Okay. It's antisocial.
Have you done any like side projects?
Because I heard new experiences better than like grades, you know,
they care about experience a lot. So did you do a side project?
I guess I didn't really do side projects,
but I worked part-time at a, uh, for a startup.
Um, but that was, it was just purely for experience.
It wasn't like I was getting paid or anything.
So it was almost like a side project. So that was just calling for them.
So what did you do at a startup?
Mostly development as well as roadmapping because at a startup you
don't really have separate roles. Like one person does everything.
So, uh how'd you even like apply to jobs?
Like did you have career fairs or did you like apply just on a website?
So I did it through multiple channels.
I want to occur first because Sanford has a lot of career fairs.
I just applied online and also got referred.
When you got, you know, your internships, like did you, for them,
like how'd you study for now.
For interviews? Um, yeah, you definitely have to study for them.
I don't think just taking classes is enough for coding interviews,
at least unless you have a class in college that cater specifically towards
interviewing skills. Um,
I think one book that everyone recommends and they recommended for a good reason
is cracking the coding interview. Um, they have all the basics,
they have the solutions for questions as well,
so it's pretty worth it to just read through it.
And then afterwards I just went online, went on leave code, HackerRank,
those things so that you can actually practice like coding interviews.
I was also in a group called Stanford consulting.
So I had done some consulting interviews before and although
they are pretty different, it does help to have some consulting,
guesstimation, that type of background, and then having.
Okay. I know why it didn't get the job now for context.
I just want to put this out there. I'm like, I didn't know her before. Uh,
I just knew her now,
but like before I remember I actually applied for the LinkedIn role as a
PM, same year I did not get it.
So in some ways we crossed paths and she took away my only
opportunity to become a PM.
Instead I went to Microsoft. You still working for Microsoft,
Microsoft as a PO, uh, how were you in high school?
Like where you like the nerdy type or like that, not that nerdy type,
you know? Definitely not the cool.
Or the cool.
No, I didn't put cool. I just met nerdy type and not very tight, you know.
Dirty and not nerdy. Um,
I guess I was nerdy.
Nerd. No, but like why, why? Like for example, did you join like clubs,
like robotics or blah, blah, blah, stuff like that.
What kind of clubs you're joining?
Actually, I was only in like music related clubs,
so I wasn't in any of like the academic clubs.
Um, I guess I considered myself nerdy because I did study a lot. So,
but I wasn't like the, I don't know.
What's the definition of a typical nerd who like really.
I don't know someone who doesn't socialize as much. Just think me,
I think I socialized. Oh, okay, cool. Cool. Yeah. So what about now?
Like what do you do outside of work after our long work hours?
So if I don't want to socialize, I would just watch TV,
create drama. You know, reality shows Korean dramas. You watch.
I recently I've been watching this like really intense one,
which is called PIMCO. It's like money, flour,
or something that translates to my clients.
Really intense story of how the super rich family fights for their heritage.
Classic classic.
Where a little story or is it.
Oh, extremely. There's a lot of love story inside it,
but it's like a lot of intensity.
So if you weren't a software engineer,
what do you think you would have done instead.
Being realistic? I think I would have either gone for either consulting or.
Okay. What if it, what if you could do whatever you want,
everything pays the same.
Whatever I want. Everything pays the same.
But you can't say like, Oh, travel, blogger, travel blogger. I know that.
That makes sense. Yeah. Travel blogger or a blogger or a food critic,
a food critic. You just eat because you get paid to eat. Oh,
you have to write a book.
Have you ever written something about food or you have, well,
I'll share it with you, but you do right? Yeah.
Sometimes, but mostly when I'm like, not really happy with it either. What?
I'm not really happy with it or like really happy with it.
I should find her Yelp account. No, no, no. I hate this place. Okay.
My Yelp is all like one star reviews. Really?
Yeah. Cause like there's no reason to rate a good one. Yeah.
Are you elite member elite? No. No. Okay. Right. So what about,
okay, so now, you know, new grass, software engineering,
do you see yourself doing this for awhile? Like what's your like five-year plan?
Um, if I were to stay in engineering,
I would shoot for becoming an engineering manager.
Otherwise I think I would want to, uh,
play more of a product role.
Now.
I guess what we're going to do now is that we had a lot of viewers question.
And uh, in case you don't know,
I have a discord channel and that is where everyone asks the questions.
Discord channel is on the description below.
If you want to join that discord channel. It's really cool.
We talk about random stuff. It's a great community. Yeah.
So some of these questions, you know, very career related, some of them less.
So first one career related, what was your APM internship? Like? You know,
quick answer.
My NPM internship. I liked it. I liked that a lot. Um, a lot of,
I met a lot of new people, which was the best part,
a lot of working professionals and a completely different experience.
I was very different from coding.
This one less career oriented. If you were a convincing,
gentleman's crushed to data, what qualities of his would you bring up first?
If I have any, if he has any,
um.
Hmm.
On a scale to one to 10, how annoying is Joma.
Okay. Oh, wow. Thanks.
It's more like, actually I'll be nicer and more like 12.
Do you watch anime? I used to which ones I used to, well,
I didn't watch anime. I used to read the manga.
I read like one piece and I Rodo classic. Yeah.
Do you think Joma is secretly gay.
Hundred percent gay? Oh yeah.
I have maybe like 0.1% out, but um,
I'm pretty confident.
Okay. Any low key talent or hobby?
Any low key talent or hobby? Any low key talent or hobby?
Um, talent. I don't know. Okay. Hobby. I,
yeah.
I don't need to force it if you have no talents is fine.
We can just go to the next question.
Yeah. I have no talent. Um, I think it's I like to do, I like to play golf.
I like to try singleness.
I that's it. I like to bake.
Nice. Nice. Nice. All right. If you were to start a YouTube channel,
what kind of videos would you want to make?
I think I would want to make casual videos,
like lifestyle type of videos. When I travel,
I want to film whenever I'm eating.
Everyone wants to do that and traveling. I see.
So I see you're a big lover of food. Yes. Hmm. Interesting. Explains the figure.
All right. So these are my new jeans.
All right. What were your first impression of Jola?
My first impression of him, honestly,
I thought it was really annoying.
There's a reason for it. So the first time I met Sonny,
I thought she was really who we honest and the reason why is because we're
on the same team and everyone's scattered for lunch and now it usually,
you know, crack some jokes and you don't tell some nice stories.
Everyone would laugh except for something.
She would have that face that you see all the time in the startup series.
That was why I cast her to be honest. So then I was like, am I like, can I,
like, I don't understand. I need to crack her. Right.
So then I just started talking to him where I'm like, Hey, how's it going?
And then China, you know, Cracker.
And then maybe that's why she thought it was annoying.
Kept on like kept on like giving these like stupid jokes.
I was like, they're good. But I think you're laughing out of politeness.
Yeah. I was coughing. I was pretending to laugh, but um, yeah,
he's fine. I mean, first impressions don't lie.
Yeah. She's fine too. So I guess this is kind of similar,
but what is drama like at work? I guess we can talk about what I am like now.
Jomo works hard on his videos
and that's true. So I don't know about work,
but he's working hard on something.
So there's this time when Joel was sitting next to me and he was like typing a
lot of code. So I thought, wow, this guy is like actually working this time.
So I got up here at over and was like, Oh, what's your working at?
And then I saw him just writing a lot of HTML code,
which clearly they assigned to us. Don't write. I was like, okay,
you're clearly not working on your real work. You're making your website.
I was making my merch shop. Yeah.
That's the one I thought that one time I was going to be like, wow,
you're actually working. Like, I was literally like this like earphones on me.
I'm like, hi.
So apparently I have 2% Korean viewership, 2%,
2%. And one of them, yeah, 2% Koreans. And then one of them said,
say something to your Korean fans, you know, in Korea, maybe.
Um, cool Korean fans now
[inaudible], you know what I'm
[inaudible] on Dawn.
It's a key lock kill off Krakatoan quality video.
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] thank you so much for your kind words. Um, yeah.
[Inaudible] you know what I'm
[inaudible] on Dawn. It's a key block.
It came up Krakatoan
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Thank you so much for your kind words. Um, yeah. All right. So that's about it.
That's it for now? Uh,
I just want to say thank you so much for watching this video. If you like it,
don't forget to press the subscribe button and also press the bell button.
If you want to get notified.
Whenever I go live or whenever I post a new video and don't forget to
follow me and who else? I know it was just me on Instagram is Jomo.
HIPAA. Fine. You can flag.
All me on my Instagram at Jomo.
Thank you. Thanks for watching Altro.
Okay. Not please. You not push my emoji please.
Especially not his crotch. The. Okay.